solite storie di essere l'italia invita
a osimo video speciale il cui alex a chi
controllerà il nostro slime vediamo un
po come alex appunto perché l'abbiamo
già fatto con si ricomincerà ad essa
saluta abbiamo interessa che deciderà
come faremo lo sly non vediamo se sarà
più brava con me o con vitale e
impareremo anche a conoscerla visto che
siri già conosciamo un po meglio anche
google adwords
ma all expo ancora non la conosciamo
molto bene ma quelli non ho chiesto al
essa chi sei sono ex sono qui per
aiutarti molto per funziona l'ex sede
rai in base a vari ingredienti e vedremo
cosa serie per me cosa sceglie per
vitale alla fine del video che metterò
qua il sondaggio in cui potrete votare
vita rigiocare se ho vinto io per vinto
e vitale in volta la bellezza dei
problemi sony smr quindi un pò come si
comporterà lei se prendete in simpatia
me evitare è sicuramente me perché io
sono più dolci palermo verrà
consigliateci pure nei commenti che
attrezzarle disfare con alec st
se questo video radure 10 mila mi piace
faremo la challenge nextar contro stili
in memoria di vedere come sir alex tra
contro series sono mai più bravo le
prima deve essere un bel like e
consigliate saputo che al tracciamento
ricordo
allora abbiamo qua le nostre
stakeholders vediamo chi inizia per
primo carta fornisce tasse esempio da
allora in realtà letta è un po più
intelligente di sir quindi non c entrano
nel tempo possiamo proprio a chiederle
il colore essa di colore a caso secondo
me può fare una prova e porta dovresti
universo come faccio a fare il marrone
foca perchè si fa questo numero ci sono
anche un marrone ha iniziato la guerra è
non ce la faccio a far questo marrone ad
abbattere dirotto è un po di viola ma
secondo che sembra bellissimo sulla
perfetta
sì posso credere tocca a te alex al di
un colore a caso john's school bus o no
ma perché utilizzare come morrone bocca
ma ti sembra normale
così offesa
siccome simpatia luna alex sa qual è il
tuo colore preferito
l'ingv è rus ovviamente così
ma perché allora vediamo se mi esce
questo marrone sporca ma dal dott
ma c'era già con me non capisco l'ho
trattata così bene finora per far
marrone foga stiamo utilizzando un po di
rosso
voglio proprio vedere cosa sceglie dopo
con i coloranti ci vuole solo un pizzico
di viola per farlo marrone felice
veniamo infatti per il riscatto il bello
tappa la comunità mila in viola adesso
ma dimmi tu guardare ho mai sentito ora
che vince varrone proc
basta basta secondo me è bastato iamm
ottimali del bisogno di un gala qui no
il caso dio è schiavo
devo aggiungere un po di brio lasci
viene messo troppo orso secondo me nda
ma almeno ha fatti click qui mi sembra
proprio che serio entrato un po
marroncino e un po marroncino violetto
per fortuna non è super marroncino ma
chi andava bene è giusto perché non
avevamo il marrone foca non penso che
nessuno vi al marrone foca arcata
comunque marroncino lo stesso 6 cappetta
misurata mi compete
ma ha presentato fortunati di alla
scuola bus
grazie alex rins mi ha consigliato bene
vedi ma guardate che tutte le paillettes
gialle sul tema scuola ministri
dobbiamo cioè deve sorreggere i
coloranti equa me la sto temendo uno per
perché se già scelto il marrone epoca
per me non al carcere cosa segnerà
adesso ma vediamo chi inizia per primo
da tanti colori c'è anche il nero di un
colore a caso quando vivo oro vivo è il
villeggiante vedere abbiamo il colore
vivo quindi un grande giallo hanno manco
m'è piaciuto molto chiara non è un po di
un animale non ma un mondo dorato questo
qui orange sa che l'eurozona che fortuna
vivo vedere cosa per me più brutta alexa
scegli un colore a caso alle orchidee
qualche idea può essere bianca via miola
l'ordigno
non si sa neanche viola si va bene
perché colori strani che si vabbè prendo
il viola magari non migliora un pochino
tg magari diventata miss può essere
allora vai con il dolore per fare il mio
rovero fortuna ma dovrò aggiungere solo
io aggiungo 1 2 gocce al massimo perché
già giallo però vediamo se esce oro vero
ho fatto lo slime oro vero guardate che
se gli basta così non bisogna
aggiungerne altro chi è brillante o
numero quando raggiungiamo il colore
orchidea al mio marrone fox vediamo come
tutti speriamo che lo salvi un po perché
era un pò strano colore ma finita che
riesce davvero il galaxy nome giusto
remi e se davvero il marrone foca
che bello per fortuna l'ha migliorato
questo colore orchidea mani ancora
vedere cos'altro si esce adesso vediamo
un po per il sesto round abbiamo queste
scagliette brillantina the blue can di b
lanciato pure fishbowl viola cagnette
brillantinati gialle che ero video nome
oppure abbiamo tantissime decorazioni di
tantissimi colori quindi si può
sbizzarrire alexa su qualsiasi cosa si
qualsiasi colore strano sceglierà visto
che se gli onori strani lo troveremo qua
ho qua
che bello rimasti meno fra di rinuncia
al essa dimmi un colore a caso morgan
mogano scuro ma secondo me modo non può
essere questo non sei stato fortunato
dai hai preso una bella decorazione
vediamo un metodo di ha detto ho
comprato presenti al danno un colore a
caso
[Musica]
pino iove scelte perché è uno stop più
simpatico dell'ex tu sei chiamata le
loro vecchio ma insomma rovesci patiti
europei che questo fosse stato qui ho
trovato loro vecchio guardate un oro un
po caduto come dire avere vitale andiamo
ad aggiungere queste decorazioni ad
allora ecco qua concordate che questo
sembra un vecchio però guardate che
bello ci sono tanti stellino vecchissimi
luccicanti non lo bello però si raccorda
loro vecchio si sta bene mai più un
galaxy adesso
lo slam preferito di vita è bellissimo
mi piace un fatto malissimo guardate
questo dover mogano mar da alex ha
scelto proprio bene per il mio online
vedevo troppo brillante alla fine
diventerà davvero rovigo si è stupendo
vediamo scaletta non solo bambino
davvero particolare il piace mi piace la
prova prova a letta sei stata brava
grazie mille
alexa con me non sei stata brava
purtroppo non trovo la risposta alla
domanda allora andiamo ora qua un sacco
di palline più fishbowl è più quelli
tellini che vi ho detto prima io sono
molto indeciso perché secondo me i
letterini si stanno meglio delle palline
nel mio perché è una sorta di galaxy
quindi vorrei lasciarlo così
quindi io spero che sceglierà insomma
questi glitter tu invece lo sai che non
lo so forse anche del forse anch'io di
glitter però forse fischi ci stanno bene
dentro quegli occhi la vtb svolto lirosi
perché stanno bene votarlo
ma tu come colore lo so però cosa fare
vediamo le maglie in esame le metto che
poi una volta le faremo scegliere il
numero invece così non dobbiamo cercare
ecco alle colore nella forza del gioco
allora sono 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 e 9
ok vediamo che inizia prima carta forno
si sa se uno mi comincio io dai alexa
sceglie un numero tra 1 e 9 su 1234567
così preso più belle e quelle cielo
color pastello bellissime
lei ci stava capita a letta se io numero
a caso tra uno e otto si più che
fortunata questi allora vado per tre i
miei fiocchetti di neve glitterati tipo
sono molto particolari
non è mia ma solo metro ma si saranno
molto bene il mio live ancora più
getterò la skandia come volevo
vediamo
[Musica]
ma chiedo la mondezza lì ma piove
bellissimo e un bellissimo garazia è
bello franci 3g bilanci bellissimo il
colore queste pallina quelli al colore
dello stein dello slam su rai 1 st
e qualcuno dello stein e ho capito ne
staranno benissimo in questo colore di
slide si stanno molto bene te l'ho detto
fortunato anche show che bello
siamo pronti per l'ultimo turno ci siamo
grati si vive di più bello albino tanto
viene ora torno quindi quello decisivo e
diamo consta marco di glitter con un
sacco di colori qui questa volta le
faremo scegliere il colore perché si può
sbizzarrire perché ce ne sono tantissime
quindi vediamo chi vi aspetta fuori si è
fatto coming out a lezza di colore a
caso la lavanda e cultura questo 90 o
questa domanda e questo questo no la
mamma rosa
vabbè come ti pare che prova lab sono i
colori bellissimi
bene saltato giallo ha quindi per fare
bene ci sono pepe di euro a lesa dimmi
un colore a caso che perde primavera
anche primavera alla primavera che si
sta svegliando dall'inverno e anche un
po giallo e un pò giallo perché non era
rigoglioso cantare stato e non ha
memoria per liberarlo primavera bisogno
per l'accordo che questo il lavanda ai
fatti sembra più lavanda a quello di
questo è il mio verde primavera best
verde erba ok quindi alexa ha già capito
che io ho la manifestazione del verde a
ecco perché io dico invece di usare
questi gialli secondo me potresti usare
questi verdi perché veniamo anno giallo
vero ma non inizialmente secondo voi ho
ragione io sì o no solo e ho ragione io
che il verde primavera
ebbene primavera se non oa sinistra
quello a destra
questo è il verde primavera bello e
verde non commentate con ragione di
balle scriviamo bene primavera il primo
risultato che troviamo dobbiamo
scegliere quel colore vediamo se non ho
ragione io
chi ha ragione ma qual è il primo verde
primavera con la nazionale di più guarda
te l'avevo detto che questo
importiamo la regione di origine
noi ha detto questo il vero non quello
un albergo voi non mi credi mai qualche
devono rovinare il mio galaxy con un po
di verde che non c'entra niente
nel calarsi il verde ecco qua il mio
perde primavera tra l'altro anche la
primavera non c'entra niente con il mio
però ammettiamolo vediamo un po come
diventa bellissimo guarda ma i glitter
ci stanno bene diventa la marrone ocra
oddio era proprio quello che voleva
letta quinta dall'inizio
com'è possibile che sta diventando
barone solo continui werder va coperto
tutte le telline questo verde come
milano
rasi liga davvero brutto non è vero io
nel mio invece devo solo aggiungere il
color lavanda che finalmente ho scelto
ed e questo sta benissimo ci sta che
bravo allenatore che fortuna alex ha
scelto tutti i colori belle per napoli
sta diventando parrocchie il nostro
dentale oro vivo come ha detto alex euro
vivo guardate sistine stupendo con i
gironi ma una volta che attivi glitter
mogano e i glitter lavanda questo è
stupendi ritroveremo chi vince allora
ora andiamo ad attivarli e poi quelli
possono vedere
dovete votare se vinco io se vinco
vitale base seppellito io l'incognita le
perché siano se vinco io so vincolante
video e vitale sono avete capito
siete pronti rullo di tamburi ecco qua
il vislab allora mi sembra che il
desiderio di alexa iniziale cioè marrone
foca si sia avverato perché è un po mar
mancino però in realtà è anche un po
violetto vedete mi piace il fatto che è
molto glitterato si vedono tutte le
decorazioni dentro proprio perché con la
trasparente anche se ancora deve
diventare completamente trasparente la
consistenza supermorbida poi una bella
con la helbers la migliore quindi super
morbida non si è indurita e supercar io
e pizarro anche le stelline quindi un po
galaxy il milione sentiamo un po di
suoni
[Musica]
ed eccolo qua mi piace un sacco perché
morbidissimo ma è anche bello quindi
sono molto contento che il mio slide
luchi però slime marrone foca scagliare
le memorie di alex
vediamo ora quello di vitale ed ecco qua
un piccolo zuin ecco il mio allora c'è
davvero strano che come che colore
strano c'è da dire che rappresenta un po
le scelte di alexa quindi abbiamo sia il
giallo scuolabus che il oro che il
giallo oro giallo oro vivo poi ci sono
tutte le palline e l'inter mogano e
color lavanda
io direi che sono contentissimo di
questo sliven perché è stupendo come il
sito più grande non è vero che più grave
è grande ed è stupendo poi guardate un
bello sempre se la folla trasparente gli
dà appunto questo aspetto così un po
opaco perché è stato mosso è stato lo è
l'ho girato tante volte vi guardate con
tutte quelle palline dvd color
arcobaleno pastello e niente adesso
sentiamo i rumori e non una frittatina
così contatti ingredienti rumori non
sono spettacolari ma ci sono il primo
datemi mio è bellissimo per 8
a questo titolo e rocco è il mio quindi
secondo voi alexa conti è stata più
brava quelli di macomer e girata con il
mio quello di vitale non mi affretto a
merola mio frittatina bellissima dice
prima di natale che si sta per essere
piaciuta questa challenge con alexa
e se volete vederne un'altra mi
raccomando lasciatemi piazze alexa
saluta ciao è un santo o quattro
cartellini cui piccata per vederci
mentre altri video